today's stream it's a blitz5 Arena this
only happens once every month let me
join before I forget and yeah I'm gonna
play the whole tournament in Zen mode so
I don't know my first opponent they're
probably close to me in raiding I'm
gonna stick with my normal repertoire
London opening time
I'll try and manage my time
uh we have this sign I played the sign
against komsky a few days ago in title
Tuesday
and this is a line like I learned from
studying comsky's games
uh 94. I think that E4 is playable
another move I encounter too often
though
because F6 doesn't work immediately
because Queen H5 check
it's actually not clear what the
knight's doing
so I probably do want to take
okay now F6 plus playable
okay we'll develop
still very london-like
I'm considering castling Queen side
kind of like this bishop G3
preparing some F4
I think the queen wants to come back and
try and help attack
thank you for da Lovelace
and I'll probably take
I'm in the castle Queen side
I have takes I would take the Rook
so lingering tension between the Bishops
it's a long staring contest
black can't play C5 because the bishop
hangs
so B5 I'm kind of like E4 here
I think it makes sense to open the
center because black has played F6
the epon is a bit more tender than usual
thank you breadman
so if I take
Queen E2 first
I'm envisioning take take Queen H5
hitting this
thank you all bets
I have this move although this runs into
F5
actually either move runs into F5
hmm
start with this
hey it's osteos appreciate the raid
hope you're doing well
this isn't so clear
huh
I mean queen H4 is a move
Queen H4 G5
I think this is the way to go like I
just don't want to lose material
also just want to keep the game going
hmm
okay
Queen H3
not the prettiest of moves
but I am pinning the pawn because um
upon is pinned H7
and very soon I want to play Bishop E5
so it still looks fine
E5 I would take it
foreign
again gifting to
really appreciate the hype
yeah shout out to osceles hope you had a
good stream
again for everyone just joining this is
um uh this is my first game in the title
Arena
actually the first Tyler Arena of the
new year
I have three hours of Blitz today
okay looks solid oh there's this move
or there's that move too
uh I'm losing upon
is it so bad
start with Rook D2
losing a pawn but I'm getting an open
file Maybe
Bishop G2
take take
and he was trying to play quickly here
foreign
yeah I think we can uh we we can expect
more collabs with the dojo
they're close by now
okay time scramble time
play this
oh that just hung upon
okay there's Rook C4
play G5 unleashing
threading this
foreign
[Music]
oh my gosh
ah
oh not my proudest time scramble
uh uh what to do what a sad start
good game though
uh oh no my heart rate okay that's a
wake-up call
I mean make sure the node's still on
I was playing someone like right next to
my reading because that's how the first
round pairings work
uh every Split Second counted there
okay
um do I go full tilta mode
I'm tied for last place at Stafford
Gambit time
I have no idea who I'm playing the
staffer gamut against but they've
already
walked into one of the main traps
the queen G5 looks nice here
and Bishop G4 coming
throwing in the check
could start with taking
I think I want to play this first
just avoiding the bishop Trading
keeping the long distance relationship
between the queen and Bishop
look
yeah this is crushing
okay this is good therapy after that uh
previous game
opponent resigns
uh okay I was playing a candidate Master
fish
back to tournaments
unless you have a quick stop would win
back on track
yeah I appreciate the level seven height
chain that's huge
and thanks everyone for tuning in
Saturday afternoon
I might as well play another staffer it
works well the first time
it's Africa at the time
yeah in Blitz it's um it's easier to get
away with
okay going into this sign
King G1 is I mean there's a few moves
here
knocking G3 that's not legal
there's five legal moves
oh no six evil moves
one of them hangs a queen
um yeah this is just a noon drawn line
I'm not gonna play for a win the way to
play for a win is Knight G3
but yeah
um
okay I drew I actually Drew someone
higher rated so that's fine
back to tournament
most of the time I do take the risk to
try and play for a win but at natal
Arena
um it was it would be too risky that's
nice to have a quick game got a point
new game new opponents a new mystery
opponent
okay I'm zero out of one with a London
so far today
we have another offbeat line
Queen G4
this is some nice London prep
like it has some nice surprise value
weakened the king side a little bit
and I don't want to trade Queens just
yet
I'm gonna go for E4
so if takes takes on d6's weak Knight F6
I probably play F3
or E5
wow
ideas Knight F5
maybe just Bishop Bishop D3
wow
okay so there's this move not only
hitting the Knight but threatening take
and take
[Music]
um
the F3 now
it looks really good
but it's going to take some Precision we
might see Queen F4 Queen G5 first
but then okay just King B1 G3
King G7 coming
hmm
each four maybe each three preparing G4
I mean G4 G5 will trap the knights
interesting
oh that's actually another bad move
a slightly annoying move please five but
that loses a pawn
taking loses a piece
maybe bishop B5
so defending D4
targeting the Knight as well
I see the plan plan is to play E5
I think I'm okay with that E5 I just
sack
it looks good
and G5 is a major threat here
we might see this move
oh but then
I miss a chance to take on D5 anyway
okay we're going into the sign
so I'm down the exchange but uh yeah
these pieces are slightly
please
King h8 is a decent move
no clean knockouts
and just develop
hmm
foreign
still not over
really
good rather take the bishop than the
Rook
on B4 Knight D1
interesting
take
hmm
anything can happen here
I didn't want to save upon
not looking good
ah what's I do
I was probably playing a strong player a
2700 kind of a great position
um maybe I should have taken the Rook
yeah because once this happened I
realized like it wasn't worth taking the
pawn because then eventually The Rook
will come to the H file
um
and it was just harder to play
good game though
that was a good fight
I feel much slower than usual in these
like these time scrambles
and probably the
mistake in the first place is getting a
little bit too low on time
just have to manage time a little bit
better
top 200
okay
again sticking with my usual openings
Queen's gamma declined
I'm gonna go for this Asics line
yeah white has a couple options which
way to Castle
I'm delaying C6 because there's cases
where I play C5 and one go if white does
Castle Queen side
yeah this is all still pretty standard
I think C6 should come eventually
Bishop G4 natural Square
thinking of Knight H5
trying to get the bishop here oh
okay eyeing H3
not quite happening though
yeah I forgot about Bishop by five
still looks okay
um
I don't want to take but
what else to do
so B5 I think I'd take and play C5
uh
these pawns are menacing
what are these pawns these files are
maybe accessible
and bishop's pinned
oh no
I'm blunder I kind of blunder you know
to play this
I'm losing the exchange or
I could take on each one
[Music]
how bad is this uh
it's interesting
probably more interesting for white
how do I get to the white king
some down material a little bit
should play B6
low B6
[Music]
um
have to try it
Rook C6 yeah
this is not good
ending at least
only goal for this game is to give white
quadruple of Hans
but it's not happening
yeah I was just losing
oh what to do
the blunder in this game was uh was
probably just G6
and then my queen and night were
misplaced
good game
uh
yeah white played volatile use the C
file
okay not my best start
not sure if Zen mode is like
helping or hurting
feels like it's hurting
just need to stay focused in these
critical moments
okay
so after Gambit has been working though
undefeated with Safford so far
Safford has brought me my only points as
tournament this is kind of funny
yeah opponent taking time
I'll play this tricky line
I think Knight here and then D or then
um DC and then E4
it was probably some kind of theory
I'll admit I don't know this too well
but I know black should be winning back
the piece
thank you Neil Heat
appreciate the sub
I'll take the bishop
I think long term it's nice having the
bishop pair
so I did lose a pawn
but there's gonna be some positional
compensation
there's a pawn in G3
now attack twice D4 likely
some point Bishop G4
here first
hmm
foreign
Bishop G4
it looks like I'm winning back the pawn
I mean there's Rook D1
Rook d8
I'm finding the taken take
okay that's a playable move
allowing G4
and then Bishop G6 thank you champ
foreign
F6
or defending F6 in the event of taking
now C5 doesn't quite work
you'll just play this
allowing the train
can I swear for the bishop now
and G4 might be coming at some point
but I'm piling on this Pawn
taking doesn't work
What's Happening Here
C5
in this move
hmm
time time's about level
play this move
um
oh no
that's not good
uh what to do
any funny stalemates
what's I do
[Music]
oh I had a nice position
just crumbling in these uh later stages
okay it's a long tournament though
it was maybe one of my pores starts with
Tyler Arena
but I'm still top 300 have to look on
the bright side
Zen mode
Sun mode has been cursing me
it hasn't been like an opening issue I
think the openings are fine it's more
like later stages
just need to
try and find my focus
some more tea
there's a trap here like E6 and if Queen
A5 I can take
some an intermediate move
yeah there's cases where
you know sort of Rook G1
doesn't like B6 is coming
and this I don't mind like here I can
play B3
although then Knight B6
maybe 6 Knight C5
five
here Rook G5
it's getting messy
so Queen is Maybe
I mean it's kind of tied down to B4
there's not too many squares for it like
there's either Queen diet or push one of
these Pawns
or Knight D5 I guess but Knight D5 I
take
so Queen d8 coming
or not
I think this works
hit the queen first Knight C3 I can take
it
because of takes I take on C6 with Chuck
and this should be my my second win of
the tournament thank you magic Harry
I could have also just taken the night
but uh
trying to get the most material here
so Bishop D4 I take
I also could have taken here and so many
options
up two Bishops
okay hey I am arunian
as opposed to giamoronian okay
so trying to get back on track be nice
to build a streak
there are 486 players in this tournament
backwards Magnus Carlson is leading
and this is not the real Madness but
maybe a distant relative
thank you
there we go
London time
yeah I'm gonna go for a night
um the 95 move
the bishop on E7
it's a little bit more passive and
allows me to play more aggressively
like there's some idea Queen H3
and now the knights tied down to this if
H6 I might take
and the problem is if ever it takes I
take and um yeah the Knight is on a big
predicament
I think I just go for it take take
although
let's calculate
there's a five in the end
the very least I'm getting a lot of
Pawns
at the very most I'm checkmating
so there's a line takes takes 94 takes
takes takes F5 takes
but then Bishop F7
[Music]
but then takes
and I have like five pawns for the piece
and I'm threatening mate
trying to identify my thread in this
position like maybe Knight G4
again 94 is a resource
so let's go over the sign
yeah this is basically what I was just
looking at I was looking at the
at this with inclusion of takes takes
but this is even nicer because I have
Knights
able to help out
um
so I take with Bishop
also take care first
have to be careful
oh I miss workout six but Rick F6 i ooh
I can't take
oh dear
yeah I blunder that
I have so many pawns though
so what's happening
I have like five pawns for two minor
pieces
take the Knight
so you're gonna be seven
this doesn't look great
I should probably save the knights
I could go back actually looks
ridiculous
foreign
to it
because now at least I have Queen G4
I'm hitting the Rook
and we might see Queen CA
I guess we're getting this position
[Music]
so I'm I'm down two pieces
for uh before is coming
attacked
foreign
pawns for the night
okay
uh that's what it takes to win a game
it's such a good opening and then I I
think I just took too many risks let's
with the the sacks but it worked out
I'm going for another
whatever this is
um
let's play the sign
I know there's h3g4
a solid piece configuration
a little bit more space
just connecting the Rooks
Queen G5 coming wow
I guess I can take and then take on H3
there's a funny line takes takes takes
I don't have Queen G3 though
okay let's move back
maybe someday light will blunder the
fact that the f1's pinned and the g-pawn
might be hanging
a2's attacked
A4 may be coming
ooh
I think I'll just be greedy just take a
pawn
more pawns are
about to be consumed
so I'm up uh two pawns here
I mean do I keep taking stuff
I'm so hungry
I guess I do
really really hungry
okay now I have to be careful
uh maybe rookie two
counter play
I'm up three Pawns
at some point I might play some like G6
or maybe I'll consume more Pawns
wait a minute Rook H1
[Music]
maybe H6
H6 Queen F5 though
hmm and queen D2
dissolving the queen trade
um
looks like it works
so Queen F5 G6 Queen F6 I take the Rook
because there's a potential pin
yeah now
I'll take here
up four Pawns
opponent wants to sack
so I'm threatening to take
yeah this should be fine
it looks scary with a queen and Bishop
in my face but uh
I don't see a follow for white
Queen G5 coming
there's actually no wave okay like I
guess had Queen F3 but uh okay
pretty smooth game
okay
new game
um you have a new mystery opponent
play this
I'm sticking with London it's been
serving me well
even though I haven't been converting
like good positions I like the sign
um I think that move is F3 here
yeah the problem for black is E5 can't
be played now I think I play E5 myself
ticks takes
now threatening G4
uh takes
foreign
there's a lot of things happening here
um but G4 is a major crack
welcome back PD bull talk
happy 28 months
the G4 is a thread but also takes and
takes is a threat
I think I can take and then F4
I can also just play G4 right away
G4 and F6
start by taking
not super simple actually
there's this Knight G4 move
nope almost premium Queen D3 I'll come
in a terrible Mouse slip
and queen D4
the point is I just want to kick away
the Knight and win the bishop I've
originally wanted to play F4 but I
wasn't sure about Knight G4 and then
later Knight F2 but now I play F4
and the difference is F6 is not
accessible after Knight G4 H3 there's no
kind of five
Queen D2
um
I'm still Queen D2
there's only so many counter attacks for
black
um
I have Queen D5
really rather than
both nights hanging
now black isn't the same predicament
with other Knights like those Knights
tied down to defending the bishop
Ah that's a move though
um
up a piece
go take essentially getting three pieces
for a rook
that's not trade Queens
and black still is alive but uh
yeah generally the three pieces for a
rook is
overwhelming
F5 should come soon
many chicks is a threat
yeah I have the D4 square and then E6
square is coming
and there's no duck to prevent 1996
a guaranteed Fork
okay that was nice
oh who did I play
I just played I Am Maverick
23 36.
so that's four wins in a row after a
pretty Rocky start
can I change the title change the title
to what though
oh maybe I should mention Zen movement
title Blitz
Zen mode
okay
uh let's play okay almost forfeited
there
okay another staff for gambits I'm
undefeated with Stafford today
so we'll see how this goes
how do you tell limbo legs
yeah this is the line I played against
faviano caruana OTV
um he crushed me like he played exactly
like this
but it can be tricky
the very least I get some early time
advantage
um take
I think this is exactly what Fabi played
because I took an H2 and
I don't think it's like that great
maybe I can take now
because I'm ready to Castle
okay
the white still may be slightly better
but I went back upon
material equality
Queen B4
threatening this tricky move
foreign
so Knight C5 is coming but then Bishop
D5
G3 now that four is coming
like Queen E4
work H1
[Music]
let's start with G3
trying to Target G2
and double edged
this Pawn is either a strength or a
weakness
or H2
oh I love that
it's not that bad actually G2 still
hangs
really
yeah getting the pawn day three is a
nice accomplishment I was expecting
Pawnee 3 from light
I don't have Queen C4 anymore
[Music]
oh this looks really nice so takes runs
into takes and mate
wow
what is really playing with fire
I think Rook B2 was just missed
yeah this should be winning
very soon
okay that was nice
uh we were about the same rating I'm
getting some rating there
uh Hey top hundred
okay
so I've warmed up a little bit maybe I
should have played the warm-up Arena
earlier to
warm up before the main tournaments
still undefeated with Stafford gabbas
the sign again I wonder it's probably
not the same opponent from earlier
I did have this line earlier opponent
took with the queen
I think Queen takes is a little bit
better Pawn takes it looks cool that
black has three Center Pawns
but there's an idea to play Knight B5
Queen G3 or queen F4
let's start with Queen F4
and yeah this is a major threat
Holland stops it
still Castle
hmm
H4
oh
I mean the main break is E4
blog wants to play this
and queen G3 first
King B1
slow playing a little bit here
92.
so we're both Castle queenside
it reminds me of an Italian structure
but our kings are just on the other side
of the board
it's like an Italian flit
so instead of the open f file it's open
C file
instead of double e pawns double d-pawns
oh maybe you should not have allowed
that
but I'm okay making some progress in the
center
five
maybe bishop E2
questioning the knights
we had a whole discussion about outposts
yesterday in this uh
late night rapid chest stream
this is one way to remove an outpost
but I don't want to take right away I
think I'll play this first
whose takes takes
a five
let me try this
sagging upon
so there's a line of Rook H4 D5 King a
takes takes Knight E5 although Bishop
takes is more likely
but then Knight A4
Knight D7
and maybe eventually take and take the
PIN
start with this
there's a funny line
it doesn't quite work though
at this point I just have to move
quickly
I really want to get a knight to ab6
um
this first
foreign
scramble time
if any meat
foreign
maybe both of us
but uh wow
what a game
okay oh I was playing chess Network I
was playing chess Network shout out to
Jerry
I had no idea
your game Jerry
and Jerry's like very very strong in
these faster time controls
okay
that may have been my biggest upset of
the tournament too
yeah Jerry is like one of the ogs of
chess YouTube and chest twitch
oops okay Zen mode
I know my opponent they're over 2700
um I forgot to turn back on Zen mode
I don't think Jerry was streaming
usually it would say
there we go okay I'm gonna play this
kind of safe solid line
um
the idea uh A5 and queen A4
I get these structures so often I mean
from London and also from Queensland
declined
it's actually Pleasant in Blitz because
I'm used to like the main thematic ideas
like preventing minority attack
we would like you to put the knights
like C2 to B4 to D3
foreign
offering some trades
um
interesting
yeah B2 is a little bit weak
I don't have my nylon D3 yet
take
maybe I can go for this
not entirely sure what's happening
so if I take take
should we Mark the pawn
oh there's Queen C4 though
yeah this is bad
okay
down upon
really misshounds with that
thank you Mr Swift tickle
happy 14 months
okay it looks like maybe I can at least
pressure the a pawn it's hard to win
because I'm tied down
to C3
my dear Queen E5
not sure what my king is doing
just kind of chilling in the center
I have recounting this is probably much
worse
I'll see
Rook A4
comes to hold my ground
and this is losing
yeah
take King F6
there's one trick
one trick
of one fell for the one trick
it's still like almost losing though
some chances
At Last I catch a stream again wish you
many good stalemates thank you
this game's not ending in stalemate
I don't think
okay oh
who did I trick
oh is this person yeah I forgot I was
playing this person
oh the game
yeah the problem is if I take this Rook
here and there's not no hope
um I was really fortunate that um I mean
A2 just wins on the spot
but this was a one trick
okay
oh no my heart rates
yeah let's hold off on predictions
um
maybe later
my zen mode
okay stop working out the time
really have to remember to turn off Zen
mode
staff or Gambit hey Stafford gamut
all I know is I'm playing like a 20
something 100 GM
20 hundred twenty seven hundred
okay here we go this is a fun line
this is a very fun line
so G3 is like the best try I think
maybe I guess there's Bishop g42
yeah this is uh this is one of the main
reasons I
still play Stafford
because even Grand Masters I'll show the
name
even GMS are capable of falling into
this
um
the outside line Queen H5
a threatening made into
haven't had this one in a while
like the double P sack
Bishop F3 I can take
wait a minute
yeah let's just
just crushing
okay
14 move win
against a GM that was nice
uh
yeah this is why white has to play G3
um instead of H3
but H3 is very logical because it seems
like Knight G4
was already a threat
and then
oh I think Cyrene appreciate the five
gifted
um and it's actually interesting too
like the engine if you turn on engine
here
it'll take a moment for it to understand
the position
Queen D4
yeah it'll say like Plus for white and
then all of a sudden
you give it more time and I realizes
Knight G4 is winning
because of the I mean it's all because
of Bishop F2
not for Bishop F2 well it would be fine
and then the fun line is takes here here
here here
and then preparing Queens like castling
which
I've had this position I haven't had
this position before
I've had this position three times I
guess
now four times
okay Zen mode is back on
see let me just make sure
that game might go on YouTube as a
standalone video
I have to still show that the Stafford
is a
dangerous opening
okay I'm top 50.
here we go not berserking back I don't
know who I'm playing
I could be playing Magnus I could be
playing backwards Magnus
at six
the F6 is a trendier idea these days
going for Bishop B5
probably just H3 Bishop H2
or Bishop G3
kind of like reverse to Obama London
interesting way of playing
considering that one
[Music]
I just want to Castle Queen side
wow that wants to really hurt me
trying to be solid
castling coming Rook CA might be playing
it
and G5 could be tender after E5
foreign
E6 is also tender
three attackers
and take with Rook
hmm
oh no my resub
we asked her reason
[Music]
foreign
I think you Pam isda thank you puck110
so really Rocky started but now I'm on
like um
eight plus game win streak
trying to find the zone
and the Zen
um
another berserk
it's too risky not knowing who I'm
playing
it's observed back
it was Bishop B4
[Music]
I want to do tactics here a bit
I think I'm better off just retreating
maybe uh Queenie Southern
trying to be active
um
might be threatening the Greek gifts
hmm trying to be aggressive
hmm
I think this works
Queen E5 coming
of King H1 I take and then retreat
wow
up a pawn here
a little bit risky looking but it should
be okay like if takes I take
Queen trade with me
uh loud queen queen G4 is playable
Queen H3
that's a free Queen
okay I'll take it
so top 30
. I'm not expecting uh
such a streak after such a
unfortunate start
39 points
I'm not sure who's leading but at this
point I don't really care just want to
take it one game at a time
um I'll play C4
and Bishop D3
a solid approach
I should Castle
Knight Knight C6 there's gonna be trades
in the center soon
ic6 I probably have to take although
maybe take your
take
for this
a nice Square for the bishop
Queen D4
huh
allowing C5 I think it's okay though
Rook wants to come in
feels like a kind of grunfelt type
position or nimso type position
typical structure with a Pawn on C4
sometimes E4 is an idea later
at night B6 coming
now allowing E5
hmm
I want to play E4 I didn't want to allow
E5 though
looks kind of weakening
C2
that's crazy move
okay so I'm turning this and this
there we go
that means Queen for nights
now long distance Queen moves won me
this game I was playing a strong iPhone
a couple hundred points high rated
okay that's a tournament
yeah the um there is a pin on the D file
so like if the night was taken I would
have won The Rook
there we go
I wonder if I'm playing this same
opponent who allowed this uh Staffing
line
but here we have an Italian
okay trading a lot
you see six
[Music]
should be okay
so G6 is my next move if G6 I just take
and I file's nice
foreign
still takes work
I allowed this move
okay
and see three oh wow
that's a move
hmm
and losing
what to do hi Eric hello
okay ah what's I do there's actually one
final stalemate trick in the final
position is if white keeps uh pushing I
time it so after King D7 promote to
Queen his cellmate
that uh didn't happen
playing a strong GM
GG
There Goes My winning streak
nice streak though
been climbing the rating
close to 2600
I think overall Zen mode has been good
for
like the quality of chess
and yeah I'm I'm deciding not to Desert
back like
I've been so especially the earlier
games this tournament
I've not been doing well in the time
scrambles
okay so we have this funny line
um E4 E4 is playable
hmm
interesting
and leave some tension
foreign
double attack Queen B5 wait that's a
free piece
and now allowing B4
where is my mate
I think it's just Queen E7
the Queen's eventually gonna get in
or queen F7 also
these pieces don't really defend the
blocking
you said no
oh wait I have to be careful still
Queen B2 so probably C3 first but then
let's just take first
yeah the bishop the bishop has served
its purpose
and queen F7 coming
okay
FM
gaining some more rating
still top 30 trying to rebuild the
streak
leader is a backwards Magnus Carlson
who I've played before I think they're
there's some Anonymous GM
pretty sure it's not Magnus
if you go to their profile
I'm not Magnus I just admire him
okay
offering a Stafford
foreign
[Music]
bush
you guys still play G4
how it takes I can take here
and takes I take and pin
um
G3 looks really nice
winning a piece
I don't know what mood number it is but
I think the first 15 moves
I take and then play Queen D6
and take I guess D3
hmm
It's Just Like Queenie Southern or queen
D6 how about
there's B6 coming
I just blunder
how bad is this
I could take
it's okay actually
this wasn't necessary but it should be
fine if takes it's actually made in two
I'm turning this and this
interesting
[Music]
I think I'll just take
this should simplify
so if takes we trade Queens I win the
bishop
and if that maybe this move
threatening meat
I'm gonna push back four though
if I take take there
I think yeah this is I'm overthinking
things just take and
be somewhat safe
Bishop 4 is still coming though
this first
I spent a lot of time
can't you choose a Target
really botching this
have 13 seconds
I spent all my time like looking for the
The Knockout blow
ah
oh that was a rough game
playing Grand Master too wow just like
hung up he's in the opening
I took way too much time
um
yeah let's let's just move on from that
still a lot more chess to go
hour and 20 minutes left
oops okay
I know my opponents
forgot to turn on Zen mode we have
London
Knight C3
I'm trying to remember they see three
take and then
pretty sure this is a line
okay
some weird line in London that I'm not
so familiar with
thank you royejo
I appreciate the five gifts in welcome
back
yeah like eventually I want to prepare
E5 but it takes time
um can I play E5 now
uh did I fall into something
I think I fell into something E5 Bishop
G5
that's not good I have to play Rook C8
I'm losing a pawn
maybe there's some compensation
be too
at least I'm getting castled
oh or not
completely forgot that was possible do I
have a night before
[Music]
okay so the queen and C Palmer hits
and B2 is relevant because I'm
threatening take and take maybe some
windmill ideas
and after takes takes takes I take on C2
first
so White's not getting much power and
play there
I think whatever white did to trap me
kind of backfired
uh can I take on E2
let's just take here
oh wow
this move
I'll play E5
this is so confusing Bishop B5
and what's happening I have this move
obstructing The Rook
saving that it's kind of Desperado move
but I'm very soon gonna play E5 and
obstruct the Bishop from defending the
Knight
a lot of obstruction tactics happening
yeah oh E5 allows The Rook to come back
in though but then I take with check so
I think it's okay
I'm takes I take and then take
with a weird sequence
yeah I'm hitting the bishop and the
Knight and the other Bishop
I already forgot who I'm playing I know
I saw the name briefly
I think it's someone higher rated
some other Queen for rook and Knight
temporarily but I'm gonna win at least
another minor piece here
all right I was playing Scarlet Dawn
okay
that determined 34th Place 47 tournament
points
I'm 40 points out of first that's crazy
hey thank you Paradox salad
also gifting five really appreciate that
okay so now I've I turned back on Zen
mode so here I actually do a new behind
playing
uh yeah this is a crazy one
like Bishop G4
Bishop G4 what if I take
black just blunder
I think black got confused
I just beat the GM in
how many moves in eight moves
didn't even know I was playing a grand
master
I'm not sure who that was
uh I'll take it okay another short form
video for YouTube let's go
now this is a danger of like blitzing
out opening prop too quickly
sometimes you'll play a wrong move and
it's
a point of no return
yeah I'm pretty sure that line is
featured in the Hans Neiman chessable
chorus
um I just studied on my own but I also
kind of referenced hans's games
okay this was the first nine of three of
today
we have a um whatever this is
actually what Magnus played against me
like he played G4 really early
recently
it's just Castle
for the hype
thank you Paradox Island
are they gaming against Vincent Heimer
recently too
along these lines
[Music]
um
yeah Knight B5 is coming
I think I'll just allow it
D4
I really want to make D4 work
idea Knight G4
I really want a sock
probably not good though hitting F2
wow
I have Knight D6
okay
hmm
if I take
I'm not sure what to do here
and this number is about five oh there's
that move I have this move
Bobby Fisher Style
what's happening though
no idea what's happening
hitting the Rook
foreign
position
[Music]
I'm just cleaning up
I was pinned
okay
I was playing uh I think this is Axel
Bachmann
strong Grand Master I broke 2600 let's
go
I'm I think I've gains like almost 100
points
approaching 100 points
okay
and it helps that I'm not berserking
back
but uh
I bled so much reading in the marathon
berserking against so many opponents
um
that it can go both ways
okay
C4 Queen B3
uh maybe 95
95 Bishop B6
should be two
let's play this first
uh
and queen is actually reasonably placed
on A3
I've been trading off everything
oh I'm pinned
uh before
yeah so the b-pawn is weak C Pawn is
kind of for the week
um
Queen B4 first
and queen B2 first
still interesting some imbalance with
the pawn structure
A4 now
wow it's like I'm on passant
I take
let's take
controlling the D file
um
that's annoying
I have this crazy move I think that's
actually okay
in blunders
oh where's my win
not so simple still
just move back
to defend the Apon
foreign
there we go
wait is this final position still a draw
this is still a draw right
I think this is still a draw
it looks winning but um
let's see who was I playing
I was playing chess ahadres because
after wait King G7 here King H6 is drawn
King E5 is winning I have to do some
weird triangulation
and then King D6
and then black is eventually
ah interesting
King F6 okay and then I come in so it is
winning
it's a good end game to know
okay
uh 27th Place not bad
Zen mode continues
we got one of these
and queen B4
now this is some line that um I think I
already messed up
I'll try and make it work
um
okay on a rook lift
I do this and checkmate
there's not too many defensive options
for black
I assume the rook's gonna move and
King's gonna try and run
I'm gonna start with 94.
okay
have this move
um
this move too threading this
as a nightmare for black to defend
if this I
um
still tricky to attack as well
queen of Fate is coming
I think I can take
an H5
some crazy lines like Bishop moves I
play rookie eight I think
maybe not though
yeah this should be winning
well it still takes work
[Music]
Chuck
mc27 first and then left the Rook
foreign
oops
wait a minute
I messed up
over there
I have to go into this it's about to get
dirty
not quite meeting
hmm
okay I feel really dirty about that
it's playing this GM Mishi again
I'll take it though
um
man oh no my heart rate
getting a workout of the stream 23rd
Place
an hour left
I don't think I've lost with Stafford
yet
not everyone's going into it though
Bishop E2 wow
Bishop E2 times multiply H5
yeah that's actually a very fine move
huh
okay I'll play this
F4 is a move
um
this should be okay
yeah this is actually crazy it's kind of
like a Halloween Gambit now
I might get back the piece
wow
to take
fancy
some other Pawn maybe I'll be up two
pawns but it's still terrifying
hmm
really
up a piece
Ah that's the point
king of seven
just have to keep the tempo
hmm
D5
still scary
so G4 I take it
probably want to play Rook B8
come on
bold decision
and G3 is a target
wow
so tricky
finally crashing through
yeah if I
if I go too soon to dig the queen I get
made in the end it was very tricky
was played vladimirovich
here's what that is
I turn back on Zen mode
oh I beat on Dragon let's go I don't
think he observed back either
that's the beauty of Zen mode is like I
I don't know who I'm playing so I'm I
don't like
I don't get too afraid of the opponent's
username or title or rating
okay top 20.
London time
modest one
it's been trendy recently
Queen b60 B3
and C3
I'm playing a little bit timidly here
just C4 Queen D2
um
A3
or that
this is going terribly wrong
maybe I can salvage this
are some Knight D5 idea
work B1 first
I hung a rook I thought it was being
clever too
[Music]
still have some time advantage
not good though
wait what
what is this
um
trying to fight
not easy though
There Goes My Rook uh what to do
oh I was playing Hans Neiman I was
playing Hans oh wow good game
oh Hans crushed my London
ah
oh he's top ten too
I well played
yeah if I knew who I was playing I would
have been um
I I probably would have played a lot
worse it was hard to play worse than
what I just did there
uh good game Hans
let me um
make sure Zen Mode's still on I Didn't
Know Hanz was playing this tournament
looks like he's berserking a lot
so I guess Hans is not the backwards
Carlson
uh let's try and be solid this game
cut my losses trade Queens
oh no
oh that's not good
this might be okay though it's
interesting
the problem is my knight is stuck
I have some kind of a five
try this first
there's no reason to come into this mess
but it's interesting
there
F5 first
let's try F5 first
hmm
um
I'll try this
connect the knights
okay now I have the B3 Square
that's all I need
okay maybe I need more
trying to get some deflection
oh dear
okay some ideas
that's a fork
wow
good move
I'm blundering left right and Center
on this other Fork
good move
foreign
well played
what to do
oh there's a carjakan plane too
this is a yeah rotten egg
well known to be carjackin
I don't think we've played yet I know he
likes to berserk a lot
okay
let's play this
the Hans inspired opening I wonder if
I'm playing the same person who entered
this line earlier
um yeah there's a cool idea to play
Bishop C7 first
Bishop F5 Bishop
A6
I think this line is fine for that but
it gets tricky
wow
it's really tricky
I mean I have Rook uh B1
[Music]
52 is a major idea
take
wow
very confusing
and group B1
oh that was ah maybe it's okay
of this move
leaving The Rook trout
I'm within the exchange
and there's some comp with a bishop pair
but this looks fine
this Pawn is annoying
like the only way to get rid of it
really is the sack
basically two I have Rook C4
I'm gonna just go after the king
how
so far down on time
I should have played Rook D5 there
still Rook D5
A5 ideas
looking better and better The Bishop's
almost trapped
I win the bishop
[Music]
um
oops
oh no
on the vagina
I'm like on the verge of winning too
yeah Ah that's disappointing
I just wandered a rook that was a great
position it was a nice opening prop
uh who did I play
and played oh I played best in Blitz as
a GM I beat earlier in the similar line
what to do
yeah it's very dangerous line for blacks
to go into
here we go
I should really learn the theory here
this looks okay though
it could be trade
we could trade some more I get the
bishop here
Bishop G5
take
huh
not so clear actually
okay maybe White's getting the bishop
here
yeah the nylon D6 is a little bit
awkward
usually it's happier in other places
and we could be trading a lot of takes I
should take the queen first
D5 Square could be used for the bishop
and maybe the Knight can
later help in attacking
uh it's not blunder the night though
orange blunder checkmate
h6s
preferable
the dark swears are a bigger concern
because white has the only dark Square
Bishop on the board
that four might be coming
wow
that four is actually really strong
and I'm
I'm in big trouble here
like the Queen's basically trapped
yeah let's try this
yeah that one like really bad really
quickly
a five
still fighting
it was basically just survival mode here
rookie sevens a move
okay now maybe I got some Outpost
hmm
Bishop E4
let's start with this
so rookie seven I play Rook F7
I'm just trying to make life difficult
for whites
it should be losing but
that's a good move
still holding on somehow
dog and move
I should probably try the thing right
should I try the thing it requires
giving up all the pawns though
um
play this first
I'm gonna try the thing
I wonder who I'm playing this opponent
might know the thing
[Music]
um
how much I do this
hmm
oh no my Rook
someone call an ambulance
but actually someone call an ambulance
yeah the problem was King H6 was also
stalemate
um there there were too many warning
signs for white
opponent probably knew what was up to
uh because sometimes white will pre-move
the pawn move but
okay I tried
okay
that's four losses in a row let me try
and um
finish a Little Bit Stronger
yeah most grand Masters know what
stalemate is unfortunately oops
you have some mode on but again I'm
playing another GM
who's about 100 points lower rated
I don't think I played this person
before
wow Grandmaster walking into like the
most basic Stafford trap
I'll go into this
Bishop D4
[Music]
on Queen G5
so there's an idea to play Queen A5
I'm also preventing white from castling
like both directions
I've Rook F1 I defend
yeah there's not a great way to defend
the knights
I don't know if I want to take the
knights
because this bishop is really strong
maybe eventually
play H5 there's takes
hmm
I think I still go for H5 though
I'm trying to open up some files on the
king side
Queen E3
accounts take
H4 wow
have this move
feels like Christmas
so many belated Christmas gifts
let's go keep taking pawns because why
not
defending keeping some pressure
[Music]
um probably King D7
Ah that's a move
I kind of got tricked
of this move
wait
I have so many pawns it should be okay
let's play this move
what
ah that oh wow that's a cool move
I have to be really careful
[Music]
hmm
that's not so simple
we have already gone terribly wrong
we still have a lot of Pawns losing the
exchange
sort of takes takes
I mean G4 first
let's take
hmm
ons go marching one by one
hurray
foreign
how did that happen
I think I just I assumed it was just
going to be easy win and when the game
ended I thought my point resigned
oh completely lost track of time
what did I do there
oh no
it's my first Stafford loss
it may have been
not my proudest moment I was also I lost
that cause opponent has a single Pawn
okay I need to find some Zen again
what is this
I'm getting trolled
so much tilt my opponent's also probably
tilting though
silk goes in both directions
huh
H7
clear targets
it's hard to believe I'm playing a grand
master right here
foreign
[Music]
I'm still having flashbacks
foreign
[Music]
threatening to take and check
oh I was about to get made in one that
would have been really really bad
very clever
you did this move first
wait that doesn't quite work
wait this move
yeah
hmm
what a weird game
okay okay
I just want to finish strong
got a little bit of time left
play one of these
hmm
oh dear
okay at least it's still playable
are we trading off everything
upon
I am feeling a little bit of the fatigue
but
just gotta stay strong
uh
okay let's try this
foreign
at least
it's a little bit tricky
foreign
oh no
I'm losing
oh
[Music]
what should you
I've learned Knight C7
I had to play probably this move
and then just win the pawn yeah
well played
I was uh El Fuji TiVo
okay
how much time is left about 19 minutes
it's been a roller coaster tournament
pretty sure I've still gained a decent
amount of rating
to
yeah some hard raking games
thanks for being here Pablo
have a nice weekend
yeah I didn't see any good discoveries
Queen
[Music]
actually where does the queen go
Queen B3
oh no I love B5
opponent doesn't play it
can I take on B7
that was Knight A5
yeah probably just Queen Z2 should have
started with Queen C2
some B4
foreign
take
not exactly what I want
and black has a bishop here
I'm a little bit worse here
E4
it takes I play this
ooh
I have to play Rook C2 there's also B5
Rook C2
probably want to play 91
I got the chance
hmm
okay
two Bishops are menacing
could be heading towards a draw though
gambling for a win actually it should be
pretty simple win
but at this point nothing is simple
I'll just take this
[Music]
um
yeah this is losing
maybe I can squeak a draw
great move
yeah wow
wasn't my game there
I think I had very good winning chances
something went terribly wrong though
so still 44th I mean still good
tournament overall I mean I've crossed
back over 2 600.
uh 11 minutes left
do I go Full Tilt alone do I start with
zerking
maybe I just try and find some Zen
Stafford Gambit Zen
or whatever this is
feels like I probably played the same
opponent before
um how the similar line earlier
wow
this was Eagle material
a lot of Bishop tension
Bishop
King F1
okay try and use the file
foreign
development
um
this doesn't quite work
got some endgame
who
if I take
ideas to play A4 undermine the structure
four okay
yeah
foreign
[Music]
I think I got away with a rook before
this wasn't the best practical decision
given lights time situation
I think this is okay
I'm sorry about five
okay the one goal is to not hang The
Rook
foreign
pack
okay
London opening time
I'll play
and queen F3 just starts it's a weird
move order Knight C6 so early
I'm gonna have Queen G3
yeah this can lead to a lot of the
trades
okay and game time
F4 F4 G3
I might see D4 coming
but it's important with the bishop
situation to have the Pawns in dark
squares
it's the best way to complement the
bishop
yeah this Pawn is uh
I guess falling
start by taking
yeah the King Pawn engines are almost
always winning
so I'll use the C file
oh okay now I have to prove what I just
said
uh
start with this
shoe for black I'm making a past Pawn
on the king side
um
yeah the king comes back but then
black is in some sort of
like I think this is already zuzuong
another grand master
and turn back Zen mode
I was uh oh Pablo Salinas
a strong player
okay
trying to finish with a streak 43rd
Place
yeah after the tournament ends I'll see
how much rating I've gained
but it's almost 100 points
this is what happens when I don't
berserk back
uh let's play a bush gas takes and then
never mind
I'll just play one of these
Italian time
I'm going for F5
yeah this is a line I think
Bishop here
some idea to take if the Knight moves
F5 was not called for
or maybe it was
interesting position
a lot of things happening
I want to trade Queens
and just a smooth
got the triple up
hmm
F2 is a target probably threatening to
take and take
uh Knight G4 wow
if I take here first
back
oops
I have to be careful
wait a minute in three nights
oh dear that was not a free night
oh yeah yeah
play this
no that still hangs meat
how to do this
I have to play G6
um
I'm just losing
some trick
really
foreign
moving there
let's go
and accounts for the tournament
oh all the weights have finished the
tournaments
let's go
okay
oh man
was that my Peak heart rate of the
stream too
I mean I was like I got tricked it
looked like a free night
I almost didn't see the pin and just
moved my queen and that would have been
better
but the problem was this this and this
is a threat
I mean the only way not to get me to I
think is G6
and somehow like the the queen Rook can
break through and there were interesting
checks
okay
so the tournament is over
congratulations to svad mefko
uh which I believe is duboff
Han's finishing in third wow good job to
Hans
top five win prize money
carjackin finishing out of the prize
money
that was a fun tournament I hope people
enjoy that
was a up and down roller coaster
I mean I started
I started with a disappointing loss and
then I had like a three-game losing
streak but then had a really nice
winning streak
so
yeah let me see
um
my stats I had a zero percent berserk
rate which isn't so common if ever these
sort of tournaments at least for me
um
yeah finish the tournament beating three
GMS
and took advantage of
the fact they were berserking
performance rating 27.56
played 37 games
and
hey I gained 111 points